>>
So, can you start by introducing yourself
and telling me about your application and
your motivations for creating it?
>> RYAN: Sure, my name is Ryan. I work with
Zagat Survey. Zagat is a fame producer of
restaurant guides in both prints and online.
Our application today is called NRU, that’s
N-R-U. It’s developed by lastminute.com.
And it’s available right now in the Android
Market. The application gives you a 360-degree
view of restaurants that are around you, and
it’s only available on Android.
>> So, tell us about how you chose to use
Android for this application?
>> RYAN: Absolutely, well, Zagat has always
been a company that, you know, the strategies
has been, we want our contents to exist as
many platforms or popular with consumers.
You know, we really like the fact that Android
is open sourced. And as well, it has the opportunity
to be on multiple carriers. And we think that
bodes well for getting the application into
as many consumers’ hands as possible.
>> So, when you were developing the application,
did you have any sort of interesting war stories,
things you ran into while you are working
on it?
>> RYAN: Sure, sure. So, you know what, we
created a very unique experience with this
360-degree first-person view. And one of the
issues that we ran into has to do it if you’re
looking around you, there might be multiple
restaurants, you know, either one right next
to each other or one right behind another.
And you end up having issues in terms of how
it – how do you display that. So, the great
team that we worked with at the last minute,
came up with this idea of a stacking logic
and that allowed us different restaurants
to sort of be over laid on top of each other
based on different qualities and priorities.
And we were able to kind of figure away around
it without kind of scrapping this sort of
cool new UI that we developed.
>> So, the real (inaudible) of having on the
phone is the phone knows where you are?
>> RYAN: Oh, absolutely. I mean, the application
is really, it’s a combination of GPS, accelerometer,
as well as digital compass. And all of those
things kind of put together will give you
a real sort of, you know, a real idea of the
restaurants that are around you or the bars
or night life that’s in your area.
>> So are there any memorable tips and tricks
that you could share for developing your application?
>> RYAN: Sure, one of the things that if you
decide that you’re going to leave the application
at any point or allow the user to leave the
application to go to a Web browser, you know,
I think the ideal experience to try to keep
it as in app browser whether than kind of
launching something externally. When you do
that, it gives a more seamless experience
and it kind of makes it seem like the application
is a little bit larger in scope when in reality
all you’ve done is you’ve taken your Wap
site and you’re kind of skinned it.
>> So, what’s your favorite aspect of the
entire development process?
>> RYAN: I think the – my favorite aspect
is definitely the speed to market. The ability
to, you know, upload and application and twenty
minutes later, see that’s alive in the Android
Market and see feedback already coming in
is really great. We were able to quickly turn
around an update based on kind of feedback,
you know, it’s just a few minutes after
the application was updated. And you know,
ten minutes later people are getting notification
update. So, you know, we’re really happy
about that process.
>> So, are there any features that you can
do in your app that you can do on other platforms?
>> RYAN: Absolutely, because the app uses
a Magnetometer. The application’s ability
to kind of map in 3D and based on cardinal
directions can only be done on Android. And
you know, really that’s the basis of the
application, this isn’t really an application
that can only done on a platform right now.
And that’s why we were eager to kind of
dive in there and create this.
>> Cool. Can you show us a really quick click?
>> RYAN: Sure, absolutely. So, as you see
the application right now. It’s showing
you the first-person view and you can actually
see a restaurant that’s blinking right behind
me, it’s showing the distance as well as
there’s a gat rating and the food quality
source.
>> Uh, that’s really cool. Thank you so
much for showing.
>> RYAN: All right. Thank you.